if something really means something to
you and gets you excited and gives you
energy when you get out of bed that's
something that you should fertilize and
cultivate in your own life it doesn't
mean it has to be a job but I think
there's something in that that's
communicating to you who you are and
it's important to give your attention to
that and sometimes that means breaking
free of the expectations of other people
and those social strictures can be
suffocating and very difficult to escape
from if you want to do something no
matter what it is it's going to be
difficult and acclimating yourself to
that earlier in life I think is
important as well so experience life say
yes to Adventure accumulate experiences
and along the way figure out you and
then commit to being the best version of
that authentic you that is your mission